[موسيقى]
واخيرا قررت انك تتحدى نفسك وتتحدى الظروف
وتتحدى اهلك واصدقائك وكل الناس وتبدا
قولوا معاي تبدا ايش تتوقعون وتبدا دايت
وبكره اليوم الموعود اخيرا وصلنا له انت
دا احكي وياك الساعه 6 صباحا عزيزي
والخياره بايدك اليمين الساعه الواده ظهرا
وسلطه الخضار مع الدجاج المشوي بايدك
اليسار الساعه السابعه مساء وانت مستمتع
بالزبادي مع عصره الليمون بس وانت رايحه
تنام واول ما توصل عقارب الساعه لتلك
الساعه الذهبيه اللي انا وانت عارفيه يصير
معك عزيزي او عزيزتي
[موسيقى]
الاتي
مين صار معه هذا الموضوع يرفع ايده لا
تستحون ارفعوا ايدكم اخر
عرض واني اني مو غريبه عنكم بالعكس اني
واحده من الناس اللي حبيت اتحدى نفسي بس
اتحدى نفسي من عمري كثير صغير من عمر ل 12
سنه حبيت اني اكون شبه باربي هذا القوام
الممشوق فقررت حالي حال اي بنت بعمري اني
ابدا دايت بس كان دايت بمعلومات مغلوطه
وبطرق خاطئه وصار يتكرر معاي موضوع الساعه
12 هذا في كل مره اول ما تصير الساعه 12
اتحول لوحش ياكل الاخضر واليابس فذاك
الوقت كنت افكر ان الخلل مني كنت افكر ان
هذا نقص من عندي هذه عدم وجود عزيمه عدم
وجود اراده الى اخره ولكن
بعد معاناه سنوات وتانيب الضمير وتانيب
النفس اكتشفت وتم تشخيصي بما يعرف بالبنج
ايتين سدر او باضطراب نهم
الطعام
للاسف ممكن انت تتوقع ما هو اضطراب نهم
الطعام ممكن نختصر معنا بجمله واحده اللي
هو ادمان الاكل اي نعم ادمان الاكل
استغربت للاسف في كثير انواع عزيزي
المشاهد من الادمان اللي انت مو داري عنها
وغيرك يواجهها يوميا انا هنا مش عشان
اتكلم عن ادمان الاكل بشكل خاص لان كل
واحد فينا عنده فشلته صديق اللي ياكل وما
يسمن صح ف موجوده هنا اليوم يعني ما حيه
تم انا هنا اليوم عشان اتكلم عن الادمان
بشكل عام ليش لان الادمان انا متاكده انه
موجود في كل واحد منا سواء كان عمره 15
سنه او 50 سنه كل واحد منا في عنده ادمان
هو يعني يعاني منه ويواجهه ويمكن يكون سبب
في تراجعه الى الوراء ادمان يمكن مسبب له
مشاكل نفسيه وصراعات ومشاكل صحيه هو
الوحيد اللي داري عنها طبعا انت حاليا
بينك وبين نفسك قاعد تفكر موضوع الساعه 12
هذا صار معي يعني مره مرتين ثلاث مرات عشر
مرات شنو انا عندي اضطراب نهم الطعام صح
لو لا ب تسالوا نفسكم
والله يا عزيزي حابه اقول لك ان عشان يتم
تشخيصك باضطراب نهم الطعام هذه لسته طويله
عريضه لازم الدكتور يمر بكل شرط من هذه
الشروط يعني الموضوع طويل فامور طيبه
وثاني شي لا تقلق ليش لان اليوم معاكم سما
سلمان الدوري طالبه طب سنه سادسه وانا
برضو هنا اقوللك صعبه شوي لا تقلق والحمد
لله بعد معانات 12 سنه اقدر اقول وبكل ثقه
اني واخيرا قدرت اتغلب على هذا الاضطراب
وصرت الفاعل ولاول مره ولست المفعول
به طيب حاليا قاعد تسال نفسك سما سمسمه
شلون سويتيها شنو السر اللي خلاك تتركين
هذا الاضطراب شلون تغلبتي على الادمان
والله بصراحه هو مو سر خليني اكون صديقتك
واكون اول حد يقوللك هذا الشي ان هو مو سر
بالعكس انا اتبعت خطه ذكيه استراتيجيه
مدروسه والتزمت بهذه الخطه والخطه هي
كالاتي عشان تواجه اي شيء في حياتك لازم
اول شيء تسويه انك تدرس عدوك فاول سؤال
لازم تساله نفسك ما هو الادمان الادمان هو
عاده يعود اليها الانسان بشكل متكرر
للهروب من الالم ونسيانه هذه العاده ممكن
تكون عاده مضره او ممكن تكون عاده صحيه
ولكن تكرارها بشكل مبالغ به هو اللي
يجعلها مضره طيب الانسان ما شاء الله
مبتكر دور كثير اشياء عشان ينسى الالم و
يهرب منه مثلا النوم مثلا ياكل مثلا يقرض
اظافره مثلا يروح يتسوق عمليات تجميل
سوشال ميديا العاب الكترونيه في كثير
انواع من
الادمان طيب بعد ما عرفت عدوك ثاني شيء
تسوي ثاني سؤال تساله نفسك ليش انا ادمن
لازم تفهم نفسك لازم تعرف اسلحتك لانك لو
دخلت هذه المعركه وانت مو عارف نفسك ترى
حنتف شل يعني ما حندخل نواجه العدو واحنا
بس عارفين العدو ثاني سؤال لازم تساله
نفسك لماذا ندمن ليست ما ادمنت على الاكل
وصديقتها لا الفكره هو بشي متواجد كل واحد
فينا السر هو بشنو بعقلك والحمد لله كنا
عننا عقل ولكن هذه العقول لها نفس الاجزاء
الاساسيه بس هذه الاجزاء الاساسيه انتبه
مش متشابهه بالضبط لا بكس دماغك قدره
عجيبه انه يتطور مع الوقت فيترك الادمان
او ممكن تصير مدمن الفكره هي بتواصل هذه
الخلايا العصبيه مع بعضها البعض الفكره هي
نوع المواد اللي تتواصل فيها هذه الخلايا
العصبيه لما تاخذ الماده المدمنه طريقه
تواصل هذه الخلايا العصبيه مع هذه المواد
تزيد هذه المواد بكميه مبالغ بها فاللي
يصير معك انك تحس بنشوه وسعاده مبالغ بها
بسبب هذه الماده المدمنه اللي ترفع لك هذه
المواد اللي تساعد الخلايا على التواصل
فتحس نفس ما قلت سعاده مبالغ بها فجسمك
يطبع بالعكس يقوللك بدال ما انا اكون
دائما في المستوى العادي ليش ما دائما
اكون سعيد ويطلب هذه الماده بشكل مستمر
فبدل السيجاره صير تاخذ سيجارتين وبدال
العلبه تصير تاخذ علبتين فالحين المفروض
بعد ما فهمت نفسك وفهمت عدوك وبما انك
الحين الى الان جالس معانا ومنتظر تعرف
السر معناها انت صدقا حابب تغير من نفسك
فوصلنا لاخر سؤال واهم سؤال والسؤال
الحاسب كيف اتخلص من هذا الادمان ايش السر
عشان الواحد يتخلص من هذا الادمان والله
هي بصراحه دائره اسمها دائره الادمان وهذه
الدائره لا مفر منها لازم تواجه هذه
الدائره وتواجه كل عنصر من عناصرها العنصر
الاول اللي هو عنصر الالم انك تحس بالم
ثاني شي تجيك رغبه رغبه انك تقوم بهذا
الفعل ثالث شي تروح وتؤدي هذا الفعل ورابع
شيء انك تحس بالنشوه والسعاده المبالغ
بها طيب عشان ما تقولون سما ما تقرب لنا
الصور انا اليوم بصراحه كنت متوتره وقلت
خلي اكل شوكولاته قبل ما اجي على المسرح
وما اكلت على المسرح عشان يعني مو تقولون
ما اعزم
عليكم ف قررت اني اكل شوكولاته بس ايش
اللي صار اللي صار اني مو بس صرت متوتره
سبب اني واقفه على المسرح صرت متوتره
وخايفه ان بكره وزني يزيد زعلانه اني خربت
الدايت فصار الالم صار مرتين وبعدين مره
ثانيه رجعت لنفس الدائره رجعت للالم ورجعت
مره ثانيه اقوم بالفعل وحسيت بسعاده مؤقته
وزاد الالم والى اخره فلازم تواجه هذه
الدائره عشان تكسر هذه الحلقه طيب اول شي
الالم الالم هي عباره عن مجموعه مشاعر
اوكي ممكن نختصر هذه المشاعر بثلاث جمل
اول شيء حزن على ماضي ثاني شيء قلق او كره
او ملل من اللحظه الحاليه ثالث شيء القلق
من المستقبل هذه كلها عباره عن مشاعر
الفكره هنا ان جسمك مو عارف يتعامل مع هذه
المشاعر انت مو متعود تتعامل مع هذه
المشاعر يمكن التربيه يمكن انت لما كبرت
حاولت تجنب هذه المشاعر الى اخره فايش
تسوي تقوم بالفعل المدمن تحاول تخدر صوت
وضجيج هذه المشاعر بالنهايه للاسف لما
ينتهي مفعول هذا الفعل المخدر ترجع مره
ثانيه هذه الالام وتعيد هذه الدائره
فالالم هي فقط مجموعه من المشاعر نفس ما
لخصنا بالثلاث جمل حزن على ماضي ملل من
اللحظه الحاليه وقلق من المستقبل خلينا
نعرف كيف ممكن نتعامل مع هذه المشاعر اول
شيء الحزن من الماضي الحزن من الماضي تكتب
هذه المشاعر وانت تكتب او تكلم صديقك او
تكلم نفسك حاول تسال نفسك انا ليش زعلان
وعادي انك تكون زعلان مهما كان الشي اللي
مزعلك تافه ثاني شي ليش صار معي هذا
الموقف كيف ممكن اتفادى هذا الموقف كيف
ممكن لما يصير الموقف مره ثانيه اتعامل
معه بطريقه اخرى ايش تعلمت من هذا الموقف
فهذا الحزن على ماضي ودائما توكل دائما
يعني خلي ببالك ان فكره هذا قضاء الله
وقدره وتوكل على الله خلاص صارت الامور
وامورك طيبه يعني كمل يعني ما ح نوقف ونظل
في نفس هذيك الدوامه ثاني شي الملل من
اللحظه الحاليه لما تكون من اللحظه
الحاليه هذا عاده يجيه احساس بالدونيه انت
تحس نفسك مو هذاك المستوى لازم دائما تذكر
نفسك انت مين ذكر نفسك بانتصارات ذكر نفسك
انت شنو مريت فيه شنو الظروف اللي عديتها
هذه اول شيء ثاني شي لا تترك ايدك فاضيه
حاول دور لك على هوايه جديده حاول مثلا
تعرف على ناس جديده حاول ادرس الدراسه
اللي انت تاركها وجاي اليوم تحضر تدكس
فهذه بالنسبه ل الملل من اللحظه الحاليه
ننتقل على اخر نوع من انواع الملل واللي
هو القلق على المستقبل القلق كنا عارفين
الحل كنا عارفين الحل انك تخطط تسوي هذاك
الجدول تمام وتلتزم بالجدول وتتوكل على
الله وتتركها صاحب النتائج النتيجه هي لله
سبحانه وتعالى انت مسؤول عن السعي فقط
فخلصنا من الالم وهذه يعني كان المفروض
تركز في هذه لان هذه هي راس البلا اتمنى
تكون ركزت نتم ننتقل على النقطه الثانيه
النقطه الثانيه اللي هي الرغبه الرغبه هي
النيه بالقيام بالفعل طبعا انا قلت لك
المفروض كنت تركز في الالم بس انت جبتها
لنفسك لو انت خلاص وصلت معاك ومو قادر
ولازم تشرب هذه السيجاره ايش تسوي خلاص ما
حد تعامل مع مشاعرك ايش تسوي حاول تبعد
هذا الشي تماما من محيطك هاي اول نقطه
ثاني نقطه حاول تبعد اي مؤثرات تخليك ترغب
بهذا الشيء مثلا تبعد اصدقاء السوء تبتعد
من الاماكن اللي فيها متواجد هذا الشيء
وثالثا اذكر ان هذه لعبه عقليه يا اما انت
تفوز على عقلك يا اما هو يفوز عليك لازم
تحاول بين فتره وفتره تقول عقلك لا وتعوده
على كلمه لا
ف حاول تحط نفسك باختصار بعلبه تبعد نفسك
عن هذا الشيء بعد ما خلصنا من الالم خلصنا
من الرغبه الحين الفعل انا لا قادر اني
اتعامل مع مشاعري ولا قادر خلص السيجاره
بايدي ايش اسوي حاول تعود نفسك انك ما
تشرب سيجاره تبدلها بشيء ثاني دور لك شيء
ثاني برضه تحب تسويه مثلا تروح تشرب عصير
اطلع بالسياره ولف بالسياره واستمتع مع
نفسك حاول تسوي شيء ثاني حاول تقرا مثلا
حاول تمشي انا بالنسبه الي عن نفسي انا
اروح امشي اول ما احس بغضب اروح امشي
وبنفس الوقت اتكلم مع نفسي فاضرب عصفورين
بحجر ثاني شيء اذا ما قدرت تغير الفعل
حاول تصوم عنه يعني لازم توقف مع نفسك
وتتحدى نفسك وتحاول تصوم من هذا الشيء
يعني في لذه انك تكون القائد لل المنقاد
لشهواتك مو لازم دائما اسوي الشي اللي انا
يجي ببالي بالعكس لازم اوقف مع نفسي واقول
نفسي اليوم لا شنو يعني لا اخر نقطه حاول
تثقف نفسك
وتوعية تثقف نفسك لان انت بعدين يمكن من
نفسك تتركها لما تقرا
[موسيقى]
وتوعية
حزين ف اعطيكم مثال نختصر فيه هذه الدائره
ونخلي هذا المثال التدخين لان يعني هذا
المثال هو المثال السائد في المجتمع
فلنفترض انت اليوم مديرك خلاص يعني اليوم
مديرك وصل معك انت يعني خلاص يعني مصختها
الموضوع صار مقادر وحسين او غضبان او او
مو مهم شنو نوع المشاعر حاول انك تكلم
نفسك اذا ما قدرت تكلم صديق عن الموضوع
حاول تتعامل مع هذه المشاعر ثاني شيء حاول
تبعد هذه السيجاره تماما من محيطك لا لا
تخليها تكون موجوده في المكتب لا تخليها
تكون موجوده في السياره لا تخليها تكون
موجوده حواليك ثالث شيء حاول انك تبدل هذا
الفعل شيء ثاني حاول انك مثلا تسوي شيء
ثاني تتفرج على فيديو يضحك جرب شيء غير
واخر شيء اخر شيء اذكر انه لازم دائما تظل
تحاول وتوقع وح تقوم وهذه رساله يمكن قبل
ما اقدمها الكم اقدمها نفسي اقدمها السما
اللي كان عمرها 12 سنه انك لا تكره نفسك
لا تكره جسمك لا تكره شكلك لا تكره شخصك
بس عشان انت
مدمن ركز على غاياتك واهدافك لا لا تضيع
طاقتك على هذه الامور بالعكس انت تستاهل
تكون دائما تحب نفسك وتطبطب عليها وتكون
صديقها مو تؤدبها بطريقه قاسيه وتعاملها
كانها شخص اخر هو شي انت دائما حتكون معاه
ساعه فاقعد اليوم واسال نفسك واتذكر انت
بشري وطبيعه البشري انه يغلط طبيعه البشري
انه يوقع ويقوم وينتكس عادي شنو يعني
واسال نفسك اليوم واقعد معاها وصدقها وكون
صريح معاها لان انت الوحيد اللي حتكون
عارف هذا الحوار فكون صريح معاها واسالها
اما حان الوقت للخروج من هذه الدوامه
ولكسر هذه الحلقه قد خلقت حرا خليفه على
هذه الارض لا عبدا لشهواتك وغايات اما حان
الوقت لتعود حرا من جديد شكرا ويعطيكم
العافيه